household energy bills are expected to
fall by 450 pounds when the new summer
price cap is revealed next week but
experts say there's still a long time to
wait before they're even close to what
they were before the pandemic let's get
more with our correspondent shiman
Freeman Powell who's with me now so 450
pounds does actually sound like quite a
lot of money it sounds like a lot of
money yes but we have to bear in mind
that this is an average so it's not
guaranteed that all households would see
this 450 pound saving and it's also a
prediction and really we do have to wait
until off Gem and make its announcements
on the energy price cap next week but
the reason why at Cornwall Insight have
been able to make these predictions is
because the price of wholesale energy
generally speaking is going down which
means that households May well see
savings uh this summer however as I say
it's only a prediction and it's still um
it still works after around a thousand
pounds more than what people were paying
pre-pandemic levels with Cornwall inside
warning that we're not going to see a
return to those pre-pandemic levels
until the end of this decade and that's
at the very earliest it's also important
to reference as well that campaigners
are warning that those on the lowest
income may feel relief this summer as
the wholesale Energy prices go down and
we tend to use less energy in summer
anyway however it may well change this
winter when of course prices may go up
and we will no longer have that
government support for households so
it's potentially positive news but we
really have to wait and see it so next
week when after make that announcement